- [Voiceover] So we have
here the square root,
the principal root, of one two-hundredth.
And what I want to do is simplify this.
When I say "simplify it" I really mean,
if there's any perfect squares here that
I can factor out to take it
out from under the radical.
And so I encourage you to pause the video
and see if you can do that.
Alright so there's a couple of ways that
you could approach this.
One way is to say, Well this is going to
be the same thing as the square root of
one over the square root of 200.
The square root of one is just one
over the square root of 200.
And there's a couple of ways to try to
simplify the square root of 200.
I'll do it a couple of ways here.
Square root of 200.
You could realize that, OK, look
100 is a perfect square.
And it goes into 200.
So this is the same
thing as two times 100.
And so the square root of
200 is the square root of
two times 100, which is the same thing as
the square root of two times
the square root of 100.
And we know that the
square root of 100 is 10.
So it's the square root of two times 10
or we could write this as
10 square roots of two.
That's one way to approach it.
But if it didn't jump out
at you immediately that
you have this large perfect
square that is a factor of 200,
you could just start with small numbers.
You could say, alright, let me do this
alternate method in a different color.
You could say, ah it's the same color that
I've been doing before.
(laughing) You could say that
the square root of 200, say
Well it's divisible by two.
So it's two times 100.
And if 100 didn't jump out
at you as a perfect square,
you could say, Well that's
just going to be two times 50.
Well I can still divide two into that.
That's two times 25.
Let's see, and 25, if
that doesn't jump out at
you as a perfect square,
you could say that
that's not divisible by
two, not divisible by three,
four, but it is divisible by five.
That is five times five.
And to identify the perfect
squares you would say,
Alright, are there any factors where
I have at least two of them?
Well I have two times two here.
And I also have five times five here.
So I can rewrite the square root of 200 as
being equal to the square root of
two times two.
Let me just write it all out.
Actually I think I'm
going to run out of space.
So the square root, give
myself more space under
the radical, square root of
two times two times five times
five times two.
And I wrote it in this order so
you can see the perfect squares here.
Well this is going to
be the same thing as the
square root of two times two.
This second method is a
little bit more monotonous,
but hopefully you see that it works,
(laughing) I guess is one
way to think about it.
And they really, they boil
down to the same method.
We're still going to
get to the same answer.
So square root of two times
two times the square root
times the square root of five times five,
times the square root of two.
Well the square root of two
times two is just going to be,
this is just two.
Square root of five times five,
well that's just going to be five.
So you have two times five
times the square root of two,
which is 10 times the square root of two.
So this right over here,
square root of 200,
we can rewrite as 10 square roots of two.
So this is going to be equal to one
over 10 square roots of two.
Now some people don't like having a
radical in the denominator
and if you wanted to
get rid of that, you could multiply both
the numerator and the denominator
by the square root of two.
'Cause notice we're
just multiplying by one,
we're expressing one as square root of
two over square root of two,
and then what that does is
we rewrite this as the
square root of two over
10 times the square root of two times
the square root of two.
Well the square root of two
times the square root of two
is just going to be two.
So it's going to be 10
times two which is 20.
So it could also be written like that.
So hopefully you found that helpful.
In fact, even this one, you
could write if you want to
visualize it slightly differently,
you could view it as one twentieth
times the square root of two.
So these are all the same thing.